where does the creation of a great story
begin i feel like um every every
creative has a different um
source of inspiration or motivation um
maybe it's a feeling maybe it's an image
maybe it's a memory
maybe all of them combined
i usually to me there's usually an image
and that image is going to guide me
along the way
when i feel lost in the story i go back
to that and that image usually contains
at least one emotion um that i don't
maybe i don't fully understand it
but i will explore that through the
story so um
to me yeah i would say
an image or a series of images
that contain in them the whole story
um and it's it's the most mysterious
thing because i um
i can't fully explain it you know
suddenly i'll be talking to someone or
i'll be reading right uh something or
listening to music
to a song or
and some or or someone will tell me a
story like you know the other day i
bought this doll and
um i gave it to my daughter and suddenly
i hear this and there's there are
coordinates there that make me resonate
and i know that because i keep thinking
about it
um
[Music]
so if after a couple of days i keep
thinking about it and i'm talking about
original stories no it's very different
if you get a commission like please
write this story right if it's an
original thing
um if i keep thinking about it um
and especially if i can tie to that
other elements that i'm interested in
you start building a world right
and i know for example when hitchcock
did south uh north by northwest
there was no story originally he had a a
series of uh scenes he wanted to shoot
and then he brought brought in ernest
lehman who's one of the best writers
ever and then they came up with a story
to tie those scenes together but what he
knew at first is he had these images you
know a guy hanging from mount um
rushmore
right so
um a guy shoots someone at the un
building
and that's perfectly okay you know of
course he's hitchcock he knew everything
but um
and then you tie those scenes together
and you have a story
um
i like you know what howard howard suber
who taught at ucla for 50 years
what he calls by association which is
when you bring together two elements
that wouldn't necessarily
uh coexist but when you do something new
comes out
right so
and this happens in life all the time so
um
for example i mean if you're shooting
underwater and you introduce i don't
know there's a fireplace down there i'm
being extreme
it doesn't belong there but what that
triggers is a series of connections
mental connections right where suddenly
you have to make that work
uh check up the dis and theater all the
time right introducing an element that
doesn't belong and that that can set the
story in motion um
so going back to your original question
i think it's images that have an
emotional backbone and i have to figure
out what that means to me
and then the story will very slowly with
patients
come out
and one thing i'd like to say about that
is
you gotta be very careful because you
gotta be patient with it
and also don't let it drag you know you
gotta find a certain balance
because sometimes you just want to rush
it you're like you know i want to know
what the story is
and you'll have a lot of good ideas
but they're not necessarily clicking
so sometimes i'll do a very quick
outline
and then i go back to it and realize
this stays this has to go you know this
is not really honest this is me trying
to get out of you know of this situation
quick enough to move on
um it's a very organic process of
discovery you don't always have the
luxury of time
i'm saying ideally if you do
you want to find a balance between
taking your time
and
not wasting time
is that normal to become lost
with your story i mean if you feel
enough
you know of a pull toward it whether
it's about you personally or a character
that you really
um
you know have fondness for
new writers
would would you tell them that you will
feel lost writing your story oh
absolutely i mean i wish someone had
told me that you get lost you get lost i
mean i get lost very often
um
and you get lost
mostly not not because you don't know
what you want mostly because um
of expectations you know so sometimes
you have an intuition and that intuition
says something but you want to make it
so much better and so original and
that you keep pushing and suddenly you
have doubts
um and you have to try to go back to
that original impulse right um
[Music]
and again the more time you spend with
it the the the more chances you'll get
of figuring it out but
um
this is the trick to me see to me that
the most difficult thing is not the
writing itself it's figuring out what
you want to write the heavy lifting to
me is
coming up with a story on the characters
and the beats
once i have all that
writing is just a joy
so the writing itself is not that
that complicated it's knowing what i
have to write
once i have that the story all mapped
out and the characters and i'm confident
because that gives me confidence and
once once i'm confident i can actually
play with it
it's a joy but it's not easy
no i mean it's not easy but um
it's like playing a sport um
only every time you you go out there you
have to learn the rules again once you
know the rules
okay you know what the options you have
right and and and you come up certain
place you come up in a spur of the
moment certain place you have practiced
before
um
what i'm saying is that it's not that
it's easy it's just what i'm confident
it's because i've done my homework and
when i've when i've got that in my head
then i could improvise you know a little
bit
so i know the scene starts here and ends
here
um can i add a little flare here that
without extending myself too much yes i
can actually that little flare
might have a narrative purpose right
i'll give you a small example for
example
i was writing this scene
and then where this character is trying
to impress
this woman is trying to impress an older
woman who she sees as a mentor right and
they're at this older woman's uh house
and the older woman says uh let's go
upstairs i want to show you something
but please would you mind taking your
shoes off
and i thought what if
she has a broken sock you know her sock
is torn right
and it's so embarrassing
and at first i thought that's amazing
and then i thought well what is it does
it fit into the story or am i
but i realize it's such a character
trait and it's such you know it's
there's a narrative purpose
if you're trying to impress someone
you'll be very embarrassed
so
not only did it stay it made the scene
well you didn't get a pedicure that week
and your your yeah your feet look
horrible anything that makes you look
you know other than what you want to be
perceived as right um
for you maybe her husband will say like
it's not a big deal honey and she'll be
like yes it is a big deal
it might be right some people it would
be yeah well she think of me i'm like
well probably she thought you were
amazing
until she saw your foot
um so you know that's
you gotta
but that only comes out once you know
your world and your characters sure sure
and the relationships
right i could see that being a real
thing i mean because you go to people's
homes all the time oh do you mind taking
off your shoes oh no no problem and then
you go oh that's right and then you're
thinking oh no yeah are they gonna think
how didn't i think of this in advance
you know and that makes the character
real